In my life, I have always been
attracted to two things.
One, filming videos.
I would always grab the family camera
and film these dramatic stories
with my little bitty toys.
And on the other hand,
my parents were always
making it a priority
for me to learn Black history,
because they knew that it wasn't going
to be a priority in my school's education.
So from a very young age,
I developed the sense of voice,
creativity and my message.
I'm Taylor Cassidy.
I’m a social media content creator
and today, I want to share with you
why social media virality doesn’t have
the impact that you might think.
So we're going to go over
to my high school years.
It was 2020, and a new app
just came out, called TikTok,
and all the cool kids were getting on it.
And I'm a cool kid,
so I got on it as well,
and I thought, "This is amazing.
This is a time for me to combine
the two things that I absolutely love
and put them into one."
And so that's exactly what I did.
Sitting on my bedroom floor
on the first day of Black History Month,
I created my first
Fast Black History video,
where I talked about a Black figure
in 60 seconds or less,
and I posted it.
And it went viral, y'all. Wow.
It went viral.
And, I mean, thousands of people
were looking at this video
and seeing this message.
And I was so excited,
because the passion that I had,
the passion that I had for Black history,
people were loving it,
and spreading it as well.
And so I continued to do it.
I continued the Fast Black History series
and along with other videos,
I grew my account.
I got 200K followers, yeah.
500K, whoo.
A million followers.
What? Like ... Wow.
(Laughs)
And when you look at these numbers,
I wonder if you think to yourself,
"Wow, this girl, Taylor Cassidy,
is so impressive."
And I thank y'all so much.
But -- (Laughs)
I also want to ask you,
even though you might look
at these numbers and see, like ...
"Millions of people are watching her,
she must have a great impact."
Let me ask you,
would you think the same thing
if I told you I only talked
to a thousand people a day?
What about 500?
What about one?
Now while you think about this,
I'll take you to February of 2021.
And it was one year after I started
my Fast Black History series.
And I thought to myself,
"Man, if that many people
looked at my videos last year,
they're all going to come back, right?
I mean, probably even more so.
Who wouldn't want
to support this message?"
And so I pulled out all of the stops.
I got a green screen, I got costumes,
I got an external video maker.
I went bougie with it.
(Laughter)
And I created my first
Fast Black History video for 2021,
and I posted it.
And in the end,
I was disappointed.
I mean, where did everybody go?
There weren't half as many people watching
as there were last year.
What was wrong?
And mind you, there were still thousands
of people watching my videos.
But that wasn't the problem.
The problem was that my mindset
was so focused on those numbers
that I thought to myself,
if millions of people
weren't watching my videos,
did my message even really matter
that much in the first place?
And because of this,
a deep insecurity developed in me,
and I started drastically
changing my content
to try and adhere to trends,
to try and make it go more viral ...
And, I mean, it worked.
I had many viral videos after that.
But why, whenever I looked at my account,
why, whenever I looked at my own videos,
did I not feel fulfilled?
And it took this one video that I posted.
It was a motivational video,
and, I mean, I had posted them before
and I still post them.
They're so much fun.
But there was this one video ...
And I filmed it, posted it,
and it went viral --
600K views, yes.
But after a while,
I privated it, I took it down.
Because whenever you looked
into the comments,
it was only spam, random emojis
and fake accounts commenting on the post.
But not only this.
I knew that whenever
I looked back at that video,
the pep-talk sentences
that I was giving ...
meant nothing to me.
They weren't connected to me,
and I knew that they were just buzzwords
that I was using for virality.
And in the end, I didn't feel inspired.
I felt sleazy.
And that moment took me down
a very important and long journey
of understanding
that social media virality
doesn't always mean impact.
2020.
We had a pandemic.
All of our social avenues were taken away.
The way that we use our voice,
they way that we interact,
was completely changed.
And so we all flocked to social media.
And in fact,
TikTok in particular had
an 800 percent increase in users
by August of 2020.
That's crazy.
That means that it's easier than ever
to have millions of people
listen to what you have to say
with the click of a button.
But that notion,
that desire for our virality,
has changed the way we think
about the definition of impact.
Who's a Gen Z out here? Raise your hand.
Let me see y'all.
Hey, I see y'all.
We grew up with this notion of fame.
We know what instantaneous
fame looks like.
We know it, and I'll prove it to you.
Look at the TV shows
that we used to watch.
"Shake it Up" is about
two girls dancing ...
But they're famous.
"iCarly" is about a group of friends,
you know, making funny skits.
But they're famous.
"Hannah Montana,"
this one is about just a regular girl
going to school...
but she’s famous.
(Laughter)
And because of this --
I bring this up
because we've grown up believing
that the highest point of achievement,
accomplishment and impact
must be achieved through fame, right?
But that makes it all the more hard
for somebody who doesn't have
a big following
to believe that their voice
and their perspective matter,
because we've grown up believing
that the bigger the following,
the bigger the impact.
But those two things don't add up.
Or, as TikTok users would say,
"the math ain't mathing."
(Laughter)
But what if I told you that you have
the power to change the world
even if you just impact one person?
I’ll show you how. Let’s get into it.
Have a clear message and goal,
and then stick by it.
Here's an example.
This is a journal entry that I wrote
at the beginning of my TikTok career,
and I basically wrote down
what TikTok meant to me,
what I wanted to do with it,
and what my goal was.
And in doing this,
I gave myself a mission statement,
so that if I ever got lost
or frustrated, or confused,
I had something to come back to.
And even to this day, I come back to this
and I abide by these same themes.
Now, for you, what that means
is this is the part
where you cement in yourself
that your perspective is needed
and that it matters.
And even if somebody else is doing
the same thing that you're doing,
or talking about the same message
that you want to talk about,
you stay steady and share it anyway,
because your perspective
and the way that you have developed,
and developed your voice in this world,
nobody else has done it like you have,
and that is your superpower.
Alright, we've got our message,
we're sticking by it.
Now we need to check
where your resolve is placed.
What is resolve?
Resolve is the characteristic
that helps you to keep on going
towards your goal,
even when there are
inconveniences or discomforts.
It's what helps you to watch
that one more Netflix episode,
even though your eyes are falling asleep.
It's what helps you to keep on
doing your homework, Georgetown,
even when you don't feel like doing it.
It's what keeps you going.
And I say "check
where your resolve is placed,"
because in sharing your message or goal,
it is so easy to fall into putting it
into seeing how many people
you can get in front of you,
seeing how many people you can reach.
And in doing that,
you sacrifice your message
and exploit it for fame and popularity.
Instead, place your resolve in knowing
that you have the very ability
to impact one person
and change their life,
because you have the ability
to change the world ...
But you also have the ability
to impact one person
who has the ability
to change the world as well.
And that is still so cool.
OK, you may be thinking,
"Taylor, alright, I've got my message,
I'm sticking by it,
I know where my resolve is placed.
So why in the world,
whenever I post a video on Instagram,
it doesn't even get 10 likes?
Why is that?"
And I'll tell you,
even though there might not be
millions of people looking at your video,
you really don’t know
who is going to stop on it
and truly take to heart
the words that you have to say.
And that brings me to my last point.
Focus on the impact of one.
You see my transition? Yeah.
I’ll give you more examples.
You know I come with the receipts.
These comments
are from videos that I posted,
where somebody was inspired by them
or inspired by my account to go out
and make a change in their own life.
And one of them even says
that they are going into their school
and campaigning for more
Black history to be taught,
the very message that I wanted
to share in the first place.
And I show you
these specific comments
because every single one of them
came from videos that a lot of people
consider flopped --
did not go viral, "unsuccessful," failed.
But that goes to show
that the videos that I posted
weren’t defined by the millions of people
that did or didn’t look at them.
They were defined
by the very ability that they had
to reach out and impact one person
to go and change their entire community.
And that is so much more
valuable and sustaining
than creating something
or sharing something
just for the purpose
of getting quick virality.
Alright.
We've got our message,
we've got our understanding
that the individual impact
is just as important
as reaching a thousand.
So why is it so hard for us to share
our perspective and our voice?
How is it so hard for us
to get over that fear?
I'll tell you one more story before I go.
[When] I was in high school,
I entered a short film competition
where I made a short film
about a young Black girl
going through school and finding
her own identity as a Black woman
in the midst of stereotypes
being pushed on her
by her peers and her classmates.
And in doing this, I was so scared,
because it was a story
that I had went through,
was a very personal story of mine,
but I pushed on anyway.
Here are some stills from the film.
“Oh my gosh, Hayley Cassidy
is just like Issa Rae.”
Wow!
Thank you, I appreciate it.
But I was so scared to make this film,
but I pushed on anyway.
And at the film festival,
[when] they were showing
all of the competitors’ films,
afterwards, a girl came up to me,
and basically said to me how much
she related with the main character,
how much she understood
what the main character went through,
and she thanked me for making
something that connected with her
and helped her to feel seen.
And in that moment,
I understood something
very, very important.
If I had let my fear of embarrassment,
my fear of failure,
or my fear of lack
of a reaction from people,
stop me from spreading this message,
I would have never been able
to give someone the permission
to let go of their own fear.
For you,
what that means is that the passion,
the urgency and the love
that you have for your idea
and your message
must be greater than your fear.
And notice how I said "greater than,"
and not that fear will be nonexistent.
Because the very fact
that fear and anxiety
are associated with your message
is proof that it has the power
to change everything.
So,
as you go on into your life,
maybe you'll go into business,
maybe you'll go into art.
Maybe you'll become
a Twitch streamer, I don't know.
They make a lot of good money.
Remember to keep steady in your message.
Protect your voice from being distorted
by gaining popularity and fame,
and understand and focus
on the individual impact of one.
Know that your perspective,
the way you act
and interact in this world,
is the key to changing it.
I believe in you.
Keep rising.
Thank you so much.